good afternoon and thank you all for
joining me
in this virtual format today for this
press conference i am not wearing a mask
i am still in isolation in the residence
in carson city
so that is the reason i'm not wearing a
mask as many of you know i tested
positive for covert 19.
i'm feeling good and i'm currently not
experiencing any symptoms
i cannot express enough my sincere
gratitude
to all of the health professionals who
assisted me through this process
as a state wheel them a debt of
gratitude for their continued service
throughout this entire pandemic although
i'm not experiencing symptoms
many nevadans who become infected with
covid do
my heart goes out to all those who are
sick with this virus currently
and especially to the families of the
more than 2
000 nevadans who have died from covet
19.
not a day goes by where i don't think
about these families in their grief
they are constantly in my prayers as all
of you are aware of the escalating covet
19 cases in our nation and in our state
almost two weeks ago i ask that we step
up our efforts to mitigate the spread of
this dangerous
and highly contagious virus i've been in
constant contact with our health
professionals
economic experts our vaccination
preparation team
and many others to assist our current
surge and possible
next steps as of today
13 of our 17 counties are flagged
for elevated risk of transmission in the
beginning of october
only two counties were flagged our state
positivity rate
is at a record 16.5 percent
and as i've mentioned we have surpassed
2 000 deaths just recently
we experienced a record number of daily
cases
2416 in just
one day our previous record was 1639
in july today we once again had over two
thousand cases reported
817 in washoe county alone
greatly exceeded their previous record
our case rate growth is at a wildfire
level
even outpacing neighboring states such
as arizona
all available models indicate that
nevada is in a red zone
and our health experts anticipated
continued drug case growth
based on current trends in fact
ten percent of all cova cases recorded
in nevada
since the beginning of this pandemic
were reported
in the last seven days that's ten
percent of our total cases have been
recorded
in just the last seven days
every minute a nevadan is diagnosed with
covet 19.
our hospitals are experiencing record
numbers
and as you heard from dr tony sloane of
renown
a couple of weeks ago they've started
treating patients in an alternative care
site
in the parking lot some of our hospitals
are experiencing staffing shortages
because they have become infected or
their family members
have been diagnosed with covid and
workers are in quarantine
due to massive increase in community
spread
we are experiencing significant
outbreaks in our institutional settings
including our correction facilities
our public health infrastructure from
our hospitals to our state health
response
is quickly becoming overwhelmed
and from the start i've made clear that
in addition to saving lives
one of the main goals of our response is
to protect our public health system
and our hospitals from being overwhelmed
let me explain this quickly whether you
believe in the science of covet or not
the reality is this it's simple
covet is filling up our hospital beds
and that threatens
all nevadans if hospital beds continue
filling at this rate and staffing
shortages continue to increase as they
are now
that means all the vans will have
limited access to the care
they may need it's not just for covent
if you get in a car accident or have a
heart attack or break a wrist
you won't be able to access care if our
hospitals are full
and there isn't enough staff this is our
biggest threat
you saw it in new york you can see it
now in el paso
this cannot become our reality
there is a consensus on one inescapable
conclusion
we are in a rapid trajectory that
threatens to overwhelm our health care
system
our front line health workers and your
access to care
so it's time to act from the start of
the pandemic
there aren't any decisions that don't
have negative consequences
weighing the loss of jobs in businesses
versus the loss of health and lives
is painful without a perfect solution
while prioritizing the health and safety
of nevadans
i am also balancing the significant
ramifications
that further restrictions will have on
our suffering economy
no states struggles with this more than
nevada
due to the lack of diversity in our
economy
i've mentioned this high wire act before
this great balancing act
and it feels like we've been living in
this no one situation
for nearly nine months now and believe
me
i understand the stress emotionally
mentally economically that you were all
going through
today i'm announcing new restrictions in
an effort to get this wildfire under
control
i am not issuing a shutdown order to
repeat that i am not
issuing a shutdown order my goal is to
aggressively try to attack this spread
while maintaining some portion of our
economy
and our daily lives that's why i am
announcing that effective tuesday
at 1201 a.m nevada will be operating
under a statewide pause
with the following conditions in place
we will keep these restrictions in place
for at least
the next three weeks at least the next
three weeks
i'll talk more about the next step soon
first i'm strengthening nevada's mask
mandate across the board
nevadans and visitors are now required
to wear a mask at all times
when you're around someone who is not
part of your immediate household
whether indoors or outdoors
this expansion includes requiring masks
during private gatherings
i will talk more about private
gatherings in a minute
in the last month or so new research has
emerged
that continues to validate the
importance of wearing a mask
they continue to be an essential tool in
our fight
going forward we will reduce capacity
in certain high-risk areas that have
been shown nationally
and in nevada to contribute to the
spread of covid19
under the statewide pause no additional
businesses
will be closed but capacity limits and
new mitigation measures
will be imposed on both businesses and
gatherings
i will start by explaining what's
changing
restaurants and bars they are currently
operating at 50 percent capacity
under the statewide pause they may
continue to operate
under strict social distancing
requirements
at 25 occupancy
indoor and outdoor no more than four
patrons per table
and seating at bar or countertops must
continue to be socially distanced
under the existing guidelines
restaurants and bars should continue to
have hand sanitizer available
and should be conducting health
screenings and or temperature checks
for restaurants and bars that serve food
reservations are required no walk-ins
will be allowed
i know the majority of our bars and
restaurants are doing their best
but these settings are proven to be high
risk because they allow the opportunity
for people to remove their face
coverings in indoor settings
around people outside of their
households that's how the virus spreads
that's why i encourage curbside delivery
and or carryout operations and why our
healthcare experts want to remind
nevadans and visitors
that you must keep your mask on at all
times
when you are not actively eating or
drinking
regardless of whether you are six feet
away from others or not
you must maintain your mask at all times
when not actively drinking and eating
if you choose to dine indoors keep your
mask on as much as possible
i encourage restaurants and bars to try
to expand outdoor seating options
and i encourage local governments to
work with these businesses
to meet this goal gyms
fitness and dance studios and places
like martial arts studios
currently are operating at 50 capacity
under the pause they may operate with no
more than
25 occupancy under strict
social distancing requirements we are
strengthening our mass mandate with no
exceptions no exceptions for indoor
exercise
masks must be worn at all times unless
you're actively drinking
if the activity is too strenuous to be
done while wearing a mask
properly you must seek an alternative
exercise other businesses that will be
moving from
50 percent to 25 capacity
during the pause include the following
museums art galleries libraries
zoos and aquariums arcades
racetracks bowling alleys miniature golf
amusement and theme parks and other
similar activities
additionally gaming operations will be
restricted to have no more than
25 percent occupancy and must
operate pursuant to requirements issued
by the nevada gaming control board
including health and safety policies
restaurants and bars
with within gaming establishments will
be restricted to the 25
capacity under the statewide pause
public gatherings recently
we took great steps to increase
gathering size to 250 people
or 25 or 50 percent whichever was less
unfortunately due to the surge we're
experiencing
we must decrease these limits during the
pause
public gatherings will be limited to no
more than 50 individuals
or 25 percent of fire code capacity
whichever is less under strict
social distancing requirements
this includes places of worship indoor
movie theaters
live theater performances casino
showrooms
weddings funerals celebrations of life
milestone celebrations any other event
where members of the public may be
gathered together at the same time
in the same place for the same purpose
no large gathering plans will be
approved during this time
again all gatherings must be limited to
50 people or 25
whichever is less if larger events have
been approved to take place in the next
three week period they must be cancelled
private gatherings in addition to public
gatherings
this statewide pause will also include
new and
necessary limitations on private social
gatherings
we know a significant source of spread
is right in our homes
we must do all that we can to prevent it
under the statewide pause private
gatherings will be restricted to 10
people or fewer from no more than
two households whether indoors or
outdoors
ten people or fewer from no more than
two
households as i said before
face coverings will now be required in
both public and private settings
whenever you're with people outside of
your household
even if you're socially distant and
while i beg all nevadans to listen to
our health experts
and the cdc by spending only spending
thanksgiving with your household members
if you choose to gather with those you
do not live with
you must all wear masks additionally
there will be a pause on adult and youth
sports tournaments
during this period effective tuesday
morning
there will be a pause on all adult and
youth sports tournaments
retail establishments including malls
will
not have to change their capacity during
the statewide pause
and continue and continue operating at
50
retail retail grocery stores
uh with over 50 retail and grocery
stores with over 50 000
square foot capacity will now be
required to have employees at all public
entrances
counting patrons to assure compliance
with capacity limits
again i want to strongly encourage and
promote online ordering
curbside delivery and or carryout
options
as a reminder every business venue and
gathering space is required to post
capacity limits
under covet 19 directives at all public
entrances
you can find downloadable capacity signs
on the nv health response website
now what won't change under the
statewide pause
brothels adult entertainment
establishments day clubs and nightclubs
will remain closed again retail
establishments
will not have to change their capacity
limit of 50 percent
but some will have new mitigation
requirements in place
additionally the following businesses
continue
can continue operating under the current
standards
and will not have to adhere to new
restrictions under the statewide
pause hair salons barber shops
nail salons and businesses that provide
aesthetic skin services
spas massage therapy and massage
establishments
body art or ba are piercing
establishments
finally community and recreational
centers
will continue to operate at 50 capacity
understanding that they provide critical
child care services
during this time of need i want to be
clear that the new public gathering
limits
do not apply to our school districts in
nevada
and i want to take a few minutes to talk
about schools now
the very first emergency directive i
issued after declaring a state of
emergency back in march
was to temporarily close schools at that
time
none of us could have imagined that we
would have some children in our state
who had not set foot in a school
building for more than
eight months since i made the difficult
decision to close schools
and their buildings we have seen our
infection rates and risk factors
increase and decrease in response to
actions
taken that includes actions that
government has taken
in regards to testing to issuing state
home orders
closures and the gradual reopening of
our economy
but also includes actions that have
taken as individuals in response to
whether or not all of us are doing
everything we can
to keep our neighbors and our families
safe whether we wear our masks and
refrain from taking unnecessary risks
let's be honest our casinos
hotels restaurants and bars are open
with strict restrictions
so that we can protect our economy
meanwhile
the majority of our school buildings
across our state are closed
and our kids are suffering as a result
our education system
and our economy are not mutually
exclusive
they are tied together as long as school
buildings are closed
our economy cannot be fully open
mom and dad can't go to work if they
have children learning from home who
needs supervision
we must re-prioritize keeping our kids
in the classroom
or getting them done or getting them
there
throughout this crisis we have been
talking about protecting our vulnerable
populations
while children are not as physically
vulnerable to covet 19 as
elderly or medically at risk
that certainly doesn't mean they are
immune to its effects
they too are vulnerable in this pandemic
and they desperately need
all of our support as i said
we have students who have not been
inside of a school building
in over eight months and while we're
doing everything we can to provide
community support for some children
that could mean that they have not had
access to reliable food
to save shelter or to caring adults who
can intervene immediately
if something isn't right in over the
last eight months
we've talked about wearing masks to
protect our elderly
our parents and our grandparents and
we've talked about staying home
so we can keep our economy open today
i'm asking you not only to follow
through with these tougher restrictions
during the statewide pause for the
vulnerable in our economy
but to do it because our children
deserve our support
we have seen more deaths by suicide
among students this fall
than in years prior and it breaks my
heart to share that victims have
included students
as young as eight years old
we are in a pandemic which caused an
economic crisis
which has created a mental health crisis
and getting children back into school
buildings is a key way that we can
ensure that they are getting the
education
and support that they desperately need
and they deserve
that's why we must do everything we can
to help prevent the spread
that's part of why i am putting nevada
in a three-week statewide pause
with restrictions i just spoke about
restriction the restrictions i outlined
tonight apply statewide
they are baseline standards for all of
our communities
but i would be remiss not to remind
local governments of their ability
to enact stronger measures especially
if your local public health officials
are giving you recommendations
or if your hospitals become overwhelmed
or if you experience outbreaks in your
counties
take action the measures i'm announcing
tonight
our statewide paws will be in effect for
a three-week period
throughout this pause we'll be
evaluating our situation
and looking for signs of concern or
improvement
we will monitor our transmission rate
the slope of the epi curve
and our percentage increase of cases
depending on the trends
nevadans can expect a few outcomes
if our percentage increase of cases
begins to slow
our epi curve begins to plateau we will
make an evaluation of whether it's a
consistent trend
or whether we need more time under these
restrictions
to ensure that the downward trajectory
stays in place
or we may consider exclusive slowly
loosening back
to the restrictions currently in place
the numbers and the virus
as well as our individual and collective
actions
determine the timeline if this action is
not taken seriously
and our situation worsens in the next
three weeks
continuing the current trajectory that
threatens our health care infrastructure
i will be forced to intervene and to
take even stronger actions
stronger stronger actions will be
targeted at high risk settings
and may include the prohibition of
indoor dining and service at restaurants
and bars closure of gyms and fitness
facilities
severe restrictions on gathering sizes
that is what our future holds if our
trends do not improve
as your governor i am confident that i
did all i could to avoid further
restrictions
and keep us on the path forward but now
i must act i am hopeful that these
restrictions announced today
going to effect on tuesday will help
reduce our caseload
i don't want to impose further
restrictions
we are too close to the real solution
the vaccines to give up now
i remained incur i remain encouraged by
the developments with the medera and
pfizer vaccines
there is a light at the end of this
tunnel and we are getting closer
but we do not have a vaccine yet
there is no doubt that this surge is a
global and national problem
but it's our problem as the veterans to
fix what we can
fix within our own state so in this
moment
with these new restrictions and with
that optimism on vaccine programs in
mind
i'm asking all of nevada's leaders
business
labor religious elected
associations academic and many others
to intensify your efforts even more to
educate
inform and model what is required of all
of us
to bridge the gap to the vaccine to
fully reopen our lives and to propel
nevada forward
once again i implore you to tap into
nevada's independent spirit in this
moment
and consider your own personal
responsibility
we decide our distance to others we
decide how long we spend in a high risk
setup
we decide whether we're going to
prioritize getting our kids into the
classroom
allowing our business to operate by
following responsible measures
and protecting our hospital system if it
doesn't feel
safe it isn't safe be determined
offer help and hope to others
believe in our future and know we are
closer to the end
than to the beginning of this terrible
pandemic
thank you i appreciate your indulgence
and i will now take some questions i
believe my staff is on the zoom to
facilitate this process
thank you governor sislek and thank you
everyone for joining us um so we do have
some hand raised this is megan delaney
governor sysalex coms director
i'll be calling on the folks with the
hands raised and then if you could
i think you can unmute yourselves if
you're on a computer using the button
if you're on a phone you might need to
dial star six we'll go first to
vanessa murphy i see your hand raised
vanessa murphy channel
8 if you could try to unmute yourself
and then you can ask the governor your
question
thank you for taking my question
governor siselek how do you
plan on enforcing for example
limitations
on private gatherings and also
this stronger mass mandate you're
referring to
well we are certainly not the mass
police but i have done
everything i could to help spread this
virus it's now incumbent upon all of us
as residents of nevada to do our part
i hope that people understand the
science that we're dealing with
the medical and health care realities
that we are dealing with
and that they will comply with the
directives that are in place
thank you for your question vanessa
we'll go next to megan messerly of the
nevada independent
hi governor thanks for doing this um i
know some businesses
especially some restaurants have
previously said that they just can't
make ends meet at
25 capacity and are gonna have to shut
their doors they just can't run a
business
uh with the overhead so why limit uh
those businesses to 25
capacity and not have them close
completely
well a lot of these businesses i think
can operate at 25
and with the curbside delivery and with
the takeout
uh joined in there it's our hope that
with the pets money that we gave out
recently
we're doing everything we can to help
our small businesses
this is a three-week pause and we're
hopeful
that uh the community will support the
businesses through other methods be that
delivery
or takeoff but the capacity will be 25
it's up to them to decide if they want
to open it 25 percent
thank you for the question um i think i
passed the host back over to randy
because i'm not good at the zoom but um
we'll do next question from bill denser
of the rj
bill thanks may hi governor um
my question was about uh whether in
formulating these new restrictions you
spoke and engaged with the counties
uh and their health facility their
health
organizations to coordinate again this
kind of goes to the enforcement question
how they will carry out uh the mandates
i mean did you have interaction did the
state have interaction with the counties
and are they aware what's coming and are
they supportive of it
well we did have interactions with all
of our partners be those the counties in
the cities in the different
jurisdictions
through the cova task force and other
phone calls it is my hope and they
always have the option to make stricter
restrictions unfortunately that has not
happened to date
and the time has come that i had to take
a stand
i had to implement strong restrictions
washer was breaking
records on a daily basis i have to do
something
and that is the reason that this was
done in consultation
with all of the various groups our
health professionals our business
professionals
our uh community partners and i'm
confident that this is the right thing
to do for our state
thank you governor we'll go to um sam
metz of the ap
next please sam hi governor thanks for
taking my question and
i'm sound are you glad you have the
ability to implement such complex and
pinpointed restrictions or do you wish
there were more uniform national
standards
for the pandemic i i certainly wish
there was a more unified national
standard we could have been much better
off from the beginning had we
implemented
uh mass mandates and social distancing
and those sort of things unfortunately
uh the task force uh kova task force and
administration
did not choose that avenue and governors
were left to deal with it on their own
and i talked to my gubernatorial
colleagues on a regular basis
different states are handling it
different ways nevada is different than
some states we have
basically in southern nevada a one
industry town that we have to try to
balance
the benefits of opening up and
protecting our health and i'm confident
that
we made the right choice by limiting it
in this manner
thank you we'll go to um john sadler of
the sun please
hi good governor can you hear me i can't
judge
hi governor well thanks for doing this
um i wanted to hop back to something you
said um in your remarks
uh when you were talking about the
importance you know of the economy
in making these decisions why did you go
with with these
these restrictions rather than a
shutdown of businesses
like earlier in the pandemic well early
in the pandemic we had a total shutdown
john and
the effect on our economy was
devastating and our unemployment
at an all-time high i'm confident in
discussion with the industry experts and
with our health experts
that if we operate under these protocols
we can safe
we can keep our employees our residents
and our guests safe
i'm confident that working together
that's a reality that's not a
possibility
uh the spread is not uh necessarily
confined to hotels and casinos
it's the gatherings and the interaction
the group that creates the spread so
we've done everything we can to minimize
that interaction of social interaction
to keep everybody as safe as possible
thank you governor um we'll do the next
question with madison mckay
madison please hi governor siselek thank
you so much for taking the time
um will you encourage or talk to county
commissions and local governments to
enact
tighter restrictions that are more
specifically targeted to those areas for
example
indoor dining in certain counties well
for months now we have given the local
jurisdictions that
flexibility that authority to institute
tighter restrictions
unfortunately until now they have not
done that
and the time has come with the cases
rising as quickly as they
are that something had to be done so i
stepped up and we're implementing these
restrictions
if counties choose to go further i
support them
in that decision uh we will be in
constant communication and contact with
them
and provide any support that's necessary
but ultimately
they will have the final jurisdiction in
their area they can make
restrictions more restrictive but not
less restrictive
and that will be left up to them on an
individual case-by-case county by county
basis
thank you governor we'll go to howard
stutz for the next question howard if
you could um try to unmute yourself and
ask
hey howard there i am what are you doing
governor good hope you're
better i am thank you how do you enforce
the 25 limit on casinos
of the strip casinos especially coming
up with thanksgiving holiday and i'm not
sure what the
you know visitation numbers are yet for
that but how do you go about enforcing
that how i go about enforcing that is we
are in uh
constant contact with our gaming control
board and our new chair
uh brynn gibson who i'm extremely proud
we have him there i mean sandra was
terrific and i know bryn will do a great
job
i had conversations with most of our
gaming
operators in the past 24 hours i can
assure you
that the full force of the nevada gaming
control board will be behind
the implementation and the enforcement
of these 25
requirements and if they don't follow
them
they will suffer the consequences as
delineated by the game and control board
and governor the the restaurant
requirement for reservations that
that falls into the casinos themselves
also the restaurants that they have to
have
those guests have to make a reservation
no walk-ins
on in those restaurants correct that is
absolutely correct all restaurants
will be required to have a reservation
system in place
and people will have to make a
reservation in order to get a table
thank you governor i hope you're feeling
better thanks i appreciate it
thank you howard um we'll go to the next
question um
fox 5 las vegas i'm not sure who the
reporter is on the line but fox5
hi governor um so my question is is
dieter prepared for another
potential surge of applicants say if
restaurants or bars
decide to shut back down due to these
restrictions well i'm hopeful that they
won't shut down i'm hopeful that they'll
be able to you know make it based on the
25 capacity i know it's asking a lot of
them
uh but i'm hopeful that the takeout and
the delivery business will increase as a
result
and answer for a three week period i'm
confident that if we get everybody
complying and pitching in that
it'll be a short time it'll be three
years but deters aware of what the
restrictions are in place it'll handle
anything that comes forward as best of
their ability
thank you governor and thank you for the
question we've got time for a couple
more we'll go to bob conrad from this is
reno bob
i thank you governor uh can you hear me
okay i can
thank you uh you mentioned getting kids
back into school
the washoe county school board on
tuesday i believe is going to be voting
to go to
full distance learning and i believe
part of that in addition to the
increasing cases
is the reduction
in available resources such as staff and
subs
are you recommending that they not go to
full distance learning
well my recommendation is that they
consult with our superintendent joan
ebert who's been working with all those
various superintendents
i can tell you this bob that the cost
mentally
and emotionally of not getting these
kids into a classroom
and having in-person education at least
part way
is devastating we need to get the kids
in the classrooms
and we can get them in the classrooms if
we can get everybody to pitch in if you
want to get the kids back in the
classroom
you want to get the teachers back in the
classroom classrooms
help us out wear the mask socially
distance
limit the group size gatherings those
are the kind of things we need to do to
get our economy back going
to get our businesses back open to
protect our vulnerable
and to get our kids back into classrooms
where they need to be
it's been eight months since kids have
been in a classroom
that's unacceptable for kids thank you
sir
thank you governor i think we'll take
one um last question from andrew davey
and then
we'll be able to wrap it up here
governor okay
uh yes hello governor um to follow up on
uh some earlier questions how do you
feel
the the federal government's response
thus far
has helped or hampered um
your efforts and the efforts of our
local public health authorities to
um to contain covet 19.
well the lack of a national plan has
been devastating to all of the states
and all of the governors have basically
been left on their own
to deal with this situation to procure
ppe
to come up with a policy to come up with
uh restrictions as it relates to health
care
or if something as simple as the
encouraging of wearing of a mask would
have happened
nationally months ago we would be in a
lot better position than we are right
now but
we're not i mean the reality is we're
not in that position
and i'm hopeful that a new policy
uh will come forward in the distribution
and the uh use of the vaccinations the
vaccines that are beginning to be made
available
so that we can get them distributed in a
fair manner to all of the states into
all of the people that need it in the
most expeditious manner possible
and that needs to be done on a national
basis you cannot have
every state fighting with every other
state in order to try to procure these
things
we need to have a national plan in place
and it's my hope that we do that
great thank you governor if there are
any there is and i want to just add
there there is hope
these vaccines are talking about
potentially some of them coming out next
month
and into the first quarter of next year
as i sit in around my remarks
there is a light at the end of this
tunnel we're closer to the end than we
are to the beginning
and that's what should give us some hope
and this is the time that you need
everybody to just reach down and i know
we've asked a lot and i'm asking more
this is the right thing to do and i'm
asking everybody to please
participate do what's best for you and
your families
thank you governor and we uh actually
will take one last question from
telemundo if you don't mind and then we
can wrap it up for the evening
so telemundo if you could unmute
yourself and you can ask the governor
your question
to consider yes governor c so like are
you considering any kind of a
penalty for those who doesn't follow
this new
mandate well certainly there's going to
be ramifications for those that don't as
howard stutz says earlier with gaming uh
with the gaming in the gaming venue we
have the gaming control board that
has pretty much uh great latitude in
determining what the penalties would be
i'm hopeful it won't come to that i'm
hopeful that people will do it
but local jurisdictions business
licensing
code enforcement bni osha
all of the enforcement agencies are
going to be made available available and
they're going to be out
enforcing these new restrictions but it
shouldn't be that somebody has to come
in
and enforce them it should be that
people understand
we want to protect our businesses we
want to protect our vulnerable
and we want to get kids back in
classrooms and if we work together
we can make all of that happening by
everybody doing their part
thank you very much governor clinton
thank you
thank you governor we'll have a press
release out to media after this is over
and i'll be able to take any additional
questions um that
folks if they weren't able to join the
zoom we'll be able to take those um via
email
so thank you very much governor if you
have any closing remarks before we end
the zoom no i want to thank everybody
first off for their outpouring of
concern about my health
i appreciate that i'm very thankful that
my symptoms were minor and again i want
to thank and congratulate the incredible
frontline healthcare workers that we
have
here in the state of nevada and those
that that took care of me
and i appreciate that but this disease
is nothing to mess around with you can
take all the precautions
and still be infected it is extremely
contagious but we're
we're not at its mercy we can do so much
if we just all work together and
everybody does their little part
i understand that people are going to
get together but shorten
your group public gatherings if that's
what you have
and try to protect yourself as much as
possible
and thus protect your families and your
loved ones so with that thank you all
very much and god bless